hey do you think this is the uh do you
think this could be the last season of
stranger things if they told you
anything or do you think it could be
you're hoping it's not
it would be dumb if it was
it would be dumb if it was the last
season it's probably it's for like
they're not they can't say whether or
not there's going to be a five until
season four is released
right and then they'll know based on
ratings based on how it does if they're
gonna want to five
it's gonna do well
like even if it's not like even if it's
not a good season i think it is even if
it's not a good season it's still going
to do well because people have been
waiting for it for so much so long it's
and our fan base is just incredible are
you excited are you excited about the
next season
oh yeah
oh my gosh you love being on set you
love being on set you love acting with
these guys
i didn't realize how much i took it for
granted until season four though because
of covet and everything we started
production march i think march 8th or
something and then closed down march
16th we had like like a week of filming
before it shut down for a two week
hiatus which ended up being six months
and um
it was it was we were devastated but it
was we got back in september and i was
like oh my gosh this almost got like
taken away for good
and before at the time which i was just
like oh back to another season
and that's what i took i was like not
only was i taking it for granted the
experience but i was taking the the
learning experience and the job and and
the love of the crafts i wasn't taking
it seriously
as much as i could have and so that i
think this season is the one where like
a lot of us maybe but i just felt like
it's really where i genuinely tried
every single day every time i walked in
i was like this is gonna be a good day
because i'm gonna make it one
that's great it felt really great and
that's why i'm really stoked for the
season